era tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi anche se
sava possiamo deciso di fare oggi è
primis per il fatto che posso fare
soltanto un video questo weekend e ho
dovuto scegliere prima entra blog ed
happy meals siccome nel weekend scorso
ho fatto ho fatto il blog questa volta
ho fatto è piscosi anche non siamo i
pari a chiunque ragazzi chissenefrega
andiamo avanti
cioè no iniziano abbiamo funzione che
partite quindi iniziavo a rainbow ride
io come al solito ogni caso di volta che
inizio è previsto non mi ricordo più
come ci si muove quindi abbiate pazienza
perché ci riprovo vai con eddy vai così
è di cos'è sta ok concordate con me che
siamo partiti da dio pregasi storia
purtroppo rilassante mi metterei a
leggere un libro se non fosse che gli
occhi mi sta sul culo flessioni soldato
flessioni 123 scansafatiche dillo che
l'hai fatto apposta food village che
cassa che agli host i livelli annessi
livelli mi fanno veramente paura già dal
nome lascia che ti trasporti nella mia
macchina perfetto questa ragazza e rari
ultimo [ __ ] modello appena uscito
2014 come potete vedere nuova di lusso
carrozzeria chi cazzo sei tu aiuto un
pervertito l'inverno ari stronzo
stante ragazzi si divenire una chicca
ornato cosa che piegava tirato un ascia
[ __ ] di gnomi armati di assa
ditelo che siete voi chi cazzo è caduta
salve ragazzi se c'è qualcuno che è
caduto prima non so chi ha perfetto se
quella è una lingua
io non ho visto niente alla ragazzi
andiamo avanti di qualche cazzo succede
non lo so sì ma è sentite mai stato in
sta cazzo di foresta squartate gli
animali o cose
ragazzi ammessi tizi mi piacciono troppo
abbiate pazienza facciamo finta di nulla
io stanotte non dormo non so perché non
faceva pochi used by di certo che possa
sopravvivere non c'è bisogno che veloce
che ragazzi ho avuto un culo assurdo non
so come cazzo ha fatto a non morire io
probabilmente non ci riuscirò mai più
ragazzi oggi vi racconterò la storia del
luogo che chi andava in bici con una
gamba sola e molto triste ve lo dico
e la cosa sa cos'è che cazzo sei ragazzi
o dio che cazzo succede madonna madonna
che stuntman
[Musica]
quest'uomo lo amo perché non arriva ai
pedali ma nonostante questo riesce a
pedalare in una maniera incredibile non
si sa come non lo voglio neanche sapere
ragazzi io non capirò mai come sto tizio
faccia up ed altro che cazzo come fai a
pedali c'è ma vi sembra
mi sembra normale che ragazzi il padre
di uk e un fenomeni di prezzo o debito
agli atti dalle parti bravas mamma così
scappa allora mi stai prendendo per il
culo
mi stai prendendo stai prendendo per il
culo ce l'ho fatta ok ragazzi io un
giorno dovrò assolutamente imparare le
tecniche del padre di un look per andare
in bicicletta perché sono formidabili
guarda blackbird cos'è flybe jet lag big
band si è rivisto ragazzi devo fare a
perfetto devo farlo per lui i costi e
questo la dice lunga sulla mia bravura
sto gioco appena riesco 1 allora uno ci
siamo 23 22
va bene così sono ancora sono con i
piedi un ospedale che fosse il terzo lo
faccio 33 44 ho vinto a flap libera user
vyp no io sono fa vj comunque come vuoi
devo andare di fatto dei pezzi di merda
chi è che mi lancia sono ancora vivo
sono vi donato ma sono ancora vivo delle
nazioni che non è infatti non è facile
si no o un melone o melo adesso n'è uno
anche più grosso album gianna la
versione 1.6 con no no c'è chi se ne
fotte
io sono fortunato
tutto lui come non detto ai ragazzi
spettate lazio un cargo riuscire a fare
sta roba perché non è possibile
vai così ma porca [ __ ]
gli skate the box fino al marg in chiave
col padre di uk vai così che oggi hai
fatto
io non ho mai fatto un cazzo di schede
box così veloce non so se un cazzo di
cazzo non penso è infatti non ci riesco
più a porca [ __ ]
vi presento l'uomo spiedino zombie
survival tema oh cazzo ragazzi devo devo
combattere gli zombie così ragazzi oggi
vi insegno come comprato degli zombie
come cazzo si è messo mai così anche a
ragazzi allora io combatto contenitori a
colpi di minchia
no
ai folle ve iphone che cazzo cioè un
livello che si vede la l'iphone ma
perché controlliamo e notifiche su
facebook invece di fare ste cagate
perché non ha senso ora sto iphone che
non vedo una sedia questa roba come se
ho visto la francese un livello su un
iphone go lo stesso ma perché incastro
madonna sa il cappello il cappello non
può mancare
no bastardi dovevo prendere prima il
cappello
ok non fa nulla non fanno una non fa
nulla non fa nulla vai così nuota
abbracciate ragazzi io allora fatemi
capire perché c'è un uomo con un
triciclo ea una bottiglia nel culo non
ha senso o che devo riuscire a capire
come mai stop 9 di qui vai vai cazzo
allora ragazzi facciamo finta di nulla
avrei preferito una ferrari a questo
comunque a perfetto siamo alle olimpiadi
e questo è su questo non c'era dubbio
aiuto sono le olimpiadi più fantastiche
che abbia mai mi sembra giusto
raga io ho capito che più vado avanti
sto gioco e meno mi devo fare domande
perché a [ __ ] c'è raffreddate che
dovevo pararla questo bastardo di merda
alla farina gioca su un kazoo cap nola
nuvola la nuvola è contro di me ho vinto
nel deretano ma con tutti i posti che
c'erano proprio di pietro allora gli
occhi sei pronto per il decollo mai così
fase di lancio
tutto pronto sollevare troppo troppo
troppo giù del cazzo a ragazzi allora
con questa andiamo direttamente nel
deretano di mamma ei ragazzi gratis
dov'è andato a finire mio figlio dov'è
il look è sparito gli occhi ragazzi non
importa devo andare
l'importante che sono arrivato alla fine
poi di duke e non me ne frega un cazzo
world sky ragazzi
altro che thor questo e per gli occhi
mills che botta ragazzi sta cosa è
troppo poter madonna che potenza è mi
servi servi serviva un cazzo di martello
sta roba il lavoro dopo di cilena
terminati porca [ __ ]
allora fermi un attimo che sto martello
na figata pazzesca povero gli occhi ora
ma che cazzo povero chi se ne fotte
questo è perché non hai fatto i compiti
lorido ok come non detto cosa che mi
manca mi manca
no dove riuscire a beccare ma che cazzo
ma perché gli manco tutti porca [ __ ]
ho vinto spinto ieri ho mangiato
talmente tanto che ho pagato fin troppo
ma non importa perché ci arrivo ci
arrivo ci arrivo ci arrivo ci arrivo ma
[ __ ] a franco tanto sul calcio fa
stronzo non mi fai niente allora si
stacca di dosso che un fenomeno click
dal rimorso e grosseto dove devo
prendere il telecomando
continua vado posti vai così premi
telecomando lancio sì qualcosa addosso
per vincere allora staccati da qui
madonna allora forse più il cuscino il
cuscino che cosa non si fa per andare a
prendere un cazzo di telecomando la
prossima volta te lo porti sul divano
cosa posso fare e rega non è così dice
capito perché quando uno si siede sul
divano non ci ha mai voglia di alzarsi a
prendere il telecomando per tutto c'è
una spiegazione cazzo attacchiamo se
attacchiamo cioè lampadario mi sembra
giusto non mi chiedete come vinto non lo
so devo dire cos'è sto schifo questa è
una è uno sport olimpionico mi spiegate
perchè perchè è partito è partito da
solo il mat rango fa da peso ragazzi sta
che è di eri tu sotto con la merda è
però artisti jazz skydiving processo sky
da buy così è così allora pycon è di
imporre cadute cazzo ragazzi mi sono
buttato senza mi sono buttato senza sono
nella merda
in realtà è morto ma nessuno se n'è
accorto proprio ragazzi comunque direi
concludere qui l'episodio era la secoli
che lo forse lo più epiche sfide mi ero
dimenticato i comandi ora non passino
altri anni prima della prossima puntata
comunque ragazzi dei video è piaciuto
come al solito sotto un commento mi
piace anche alla pagina di facebook e
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione a sera se da prestiti
scrivetemi ci vediamo il prossimo vinto
bene ragazzi
[Musica]